lui la foule grossissait plus la tension
montait même si en grande majorité c'est
dans un esprit pacifique et qui était
venu c'est à hong kong et par dizaines
de milliers pour tenter de stopper le
projet de loi sur l'extradition vers la
chine
le conseil législatif étant saturées des
élus n'ont pu s'y rendre
l'examen du projet de loi a donc été
reportée une petite victoire mais ce
n'est pas à l'abandon comme telles a
réclamé par les opposants jusque là il y
avait eu quelques heures
la situation a dégénéré
ça a duré pendant des heures les pires
violences politiques en font depuis des
années la police assure qu'elle a fait
preuve de retenue jusqu'au moment de
devoir freiner à ses dires des bandits
qui tentaient de prendre le parlement
les inquiétudes sont multiples face à ce
projet de loi qui pourra envoyer qui
compte
hong kong est expatriée aux visiteurs
recherché par les autorités de la chine
dans ce pays où la justice est
arbitraire la dirigeante hongkongaise au
coeur de la crise se défend avec une
rare émotion d'être à la solde du
pouvoir central chinois
quand ils font l'amour
reste que face à la pression d'une
partie de son peuple
elle n'a toujours pas l'intention de
reculer sur ce projet de loi
d'extradition qu'elle qualifie de
nécessaire et auquel tient mordicus
pékin au mépris des critiques et mises
en garde internationales lice yannick
bureau radio-canada encore